all right oh my gosh I love seeing the
rink that was so cool with the Kelly
Clarks sha we're very fancy here at 30
Rock um band you were something
incredible today give it up for the
band well everybody we've got time for
One More Story I discovered on social
media this is what I'm
liking I think we all set in disbelief
seeing the devastation in Maui after the
fires this summer it's one of those
moments when you think what can I do to
help and that's exactly what went
through 5-year-old Edison's mind um his
solution a lemonade stand which is
incredible so with the help of his
parents he whipped up yellow and pink
lemonade set up a table and posted a
vibrant sign and in one day he raised
get this
$220,000 for the mai Relief
Fund lemonade is powerful Beyonce new
she knew we have Edison and his mom Amy
on the line right now watching from home
on com 4 in Seattle what's up Edison
what's up mama
hello oh my gosh so Amy how did this all
start yeah so we took Edison to lahina
back in January uh so when we were
watching the news about the fires he
knew uh what where we were talking about
he remembered our trip there um and I
think he felt really sad hearing about
the kids and parents who had lost so
much um and so we were on a walk one
night as a family and he said maybe we
can have elimination stand and I can
give all my money to the people in
Laina and my husband and I looked at
each other and we thought how can we we
have to make that happen um that's such
a cool idea and so he sat all day um out
on a Saturday and raised a lot of money
everything was listed at $1 but everyone
gave a lot more than that I noticed from
the 20 grand yeah I was like that is
some good lemonade you should have open
a establishment at that point um well
Edison how does it make you feel to help
these people that needed the help
happy and proud because I helped
everyone absolutely the best feeling too
being happy like helping others makes
you happy I think we forget that
sometimes thank you for reminding us
Edison uh you guys y'all are amazing and
thank you so much Amy and Edison I'm
liking your post right now okay yeah
he's so cute well that's not all our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to RAS pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate your
kind heart so they're giving them Maui
strong fund $1,000 to help even more
people in
Lina thank you guys so much congrats on
your lemonade stand and thank you to all
our guests this hour Leslie Odum Jr Mike
for biglia Jackie Matt and Brian from
the awesome company y'all have a great
day if it's not try and change
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home